now Brazil is facing a very good at  period about their common economic  development but we have mail in many  many promise oshio problems to solve so  education for us is that the to the main  to to change that that view that we have  now in Brazil in this area's okay so  that why is so important to work on  education and especially to check out  the experience that are being applying  abroad in US Europe and even in Asia and  try to get a bid to build a benchmark  and get the best best experience to to  apply that so that's why that's why it  was important to come with a group of  leaders that we have here in inhale and  to check what is going on here